une nouvelle chape de plomb s'abat sur
la Russie mardi la Douma a voté en deux
heures un délai exceptionnellement court
une loi instaurant des convocations
notifiées électroniquement et plus
seulement par papier pour les appeler
sous les drapeaux désormais il est
juridiquement impossible d'ignorer une
convocation et de quitter le territoire
russe
[Musique]
un citoyen qui ne sait pas présenté à sa
convocation se verra appliquer des
mesures restrictives comme
l'interdiction de quitter le pays et un
avertissement s'il ne se présente pas
dans les 20 jours les autres mesures
sont l'interdiction d'utiliser les
transports publics et de s'y inscrire de
déclarer des entreprises individuelles
d'exercer une activité indépendante de
déclarer des biens immobiliers et de
contracter des crédits ou des prêts
officiellement pas question de nouvelles
vagues de mobilisation pour le front
ukrainien mais les taux du gouvernement
se resserre un peu plus sur la
population selon les médias russes la
nouvelle loi comprend également des
sanctions contre les nationaux vivants à
l'étranger des mesures qui visent à
éviter les ratés de la mobilisation de
grande ampleur de septembre 2022
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'hommes
avaient alors fui la Russie
[Musique]